who does that's Michael burner the
mutineer and the flesh
[Music]
eight thousand dead in the first two
days of or eight thousand 186
welcome to disco I'm captain Gabriel
Walker captain what am i doing on this
ship I have something on deck that
requires every trained mind available
the hell is going on on this ship Brno
is viewed by many as the cause of our
concert this does nothing from our out
my ship my way for a valuable pass a flu
but you are dangerous
shields up firing main phasers you'll
seek to destroy the Ching Empire but
glory must be earth through sacrifice
have you ever bothered to look out of
your spaceships the little guys below
there's a lot more of us down there than
there are you up here you're sick and
tired of getting caught in your
crossfire
[Music]
I think about what happened all the time
and I've heard but there's hope we must
win war but that's just the beginning
imagine the possibilities
hey everybody so this is the trailer for
the next episode as well as a little bit
from the rest of the season so I'll
dress this footage after I do a couple
of the Easter eggs from the first two
episodes so obviously spoilers for the
first two episodes if you haven't seen
them yet but if you didn't notice in the
captains office there were a library of
Easter eggs like literally all the books
are episodes of Star Trek there's the
trouble with tribbles the Waits Eden
Mirror Mirror remember I mentioned they
said they were doing Mirror Universe
this season they didn't say which
episode they would start doing it but
there's return to tomorrow patterns of
force all our yesterday's whom gods
destroy the deadly years Plato's
stepchildren a mock time metamorphosis
City on the edge of forever mark of
Gideon the cage which is an even deeper
Easter egg because it's the original
pilot for the original series before
they reshot it with William Shatner so
you have Jeffrey hunter playing Captain
Pike you have Spock who's his first
officer then they reshot the pilot and
you got the first actual episode but
because discovery is taking place 10
years before the original series right
now
Captain Pike is flying around in the
enterprise in a different part of the
galaxy with a way they're envisioning
the series we might run into them once
or twice but I'm not expecting them to
be a big force on the TV show I'd be
very surprised if we ran into the
enterprise the first half of the season
but then there's balance of terror by
any other name the Omega glory the
empath in that which survives so there
was a lot of original series Easter eggs
in the episode but a lot of you were
wondering you know just a look and feel
of the ships of the uniforms in the
trailer obviously you see her wearing
the classic Star Trek colors so I think
one of the biggest surprises from those
first two episodes are the way they
shoot it as sort of a prequel for the
real series like Episode three where we
actually meet the discovery in its
captain and the rest of its crew is
where the series really begins like the
TV shows called Star Trek discovery but
the first two episodes just wound up
being the set up for the series like
this is what's happening in the galaxy
this is how the Klingons feel about
everyone else there's this big war that
started so you have sort of the Deep
Space nine
Dominion war in the background set
against the weekly adventures you'd see
on next gen or Voyager the ship based
shows in the background they snuck in a
bottle of Chateau Picard so just for
reference the cage like the original
pilot for Star Trek with Captain Pike
that was 2250 for two years before this
is happening here there were a number of
things that they borrowed from previous
Trek that I didn't quite consider Easter
eggs like the Vulcan nerve pinch isn't
an easter egg
but the Vulcan Learning Centre is
designed based on the Abrams movies so
even though they're saying this is prime
timeline they're still borrowing
visually from some of the Abrams movies
there are a couple of Easter eggs and
the names of all the Federation ships as
they punch in is they're all going at
each other
there's the Edison which was featured in
one of the video games in one of the
ebooks
there's the Jaeger which was featured on
Deep Space 9 and looks like an altered
version of Voyager but obviously Voyager
is happening way further in the future
so it's much more highly advanced there
were a couple of Klingon Easter eggs so
if you were watching this outside of the
United States using Netflix they
actually have the option for you to
watch it with Klingon subtitles so you
get everybody's lines translated into
Klingon so it can be a little bit
distracting if you watch the entire
episode like that but it is fun to play
with but it's only available on Netflix
not on CBS all access there was a whole
bunch of mud in the previous trailers
from the original series with the
tribbles but you don't see him anywhere
in these first two episodes but they do
name-drop de nadu 5 which was actually
mentioned during the troubles with
tribbles episode but just in general
they borrowed a lot of the sounds the
sights of Star Trek there were a couple
lens flares in the transitions which is
another Abrams thing they also kind of
opened in the same way that the original
Abrams movies opened with that big
disaster with the Romulans except it's
the Klingons this time sort of setting
up this big war they're gonna be
fighting and the reason why I referenced
the deep space 9 Dominion war is because
it sounds like this will be a bigger
thing but I did like the way they
treated the Klingons storyline so it
gives them an arc that just goes beyond
being nameless bad guys like oh the
Klingons are here they're gonna blow us
up we better blow them up first or try
to win them over somehow so even though
they killed the main character in the
first episode like they killed Michelle
yeah I wouldn't be surprised if we also
get a couple
they're Klingon main characters that we
get to know over the course of the
series so just looking at that episode
three trailer you sort of get this story
about how she stripped of her rank but
she gets put back into commission they
need as many trained hands as they can
get and they need people that are
experienced with the Klingons which
Michael has so she gets that get out of
jail free card but everybody's looking
at her with saya die just waiting for
her to do something bad again and
everything to go off the rails we see
her go up against the Klingon that was
actually against to come but in the
first episode so you have like the whole
council coming together at the light of
Kahless but there was the one Klingon
who's like I'm going to come for you
later like he's gonna be the big bad of
the series he might be pissed because he
wanted the right to kill to come and she
did it before he could get to him so
we'll see what their relationship is
like but it is kind of strange seeing
her back on a Klingon ship so soon after
their last encounter but then you just
get a montage of some of their weekly
adventures so obviously there's a lot of
serialization in this because you have
that war going on in the background but
it seems like they're not completely
abandoning the idea of starting and
finishing in adventure within a single
episode but what will probably happen is
is I'll do a wrap-up video at the end of
the first half of the season or the end
of the season there's only supposed to
be 15 or 17 episodes I've seen people
quote different numbers but the thing is
is the biggest complaints that I've seen
is that CBS paywall like so many people
are either ambivalent about it like okay
you know I'll watch it because I'm a
trek fan or they really like it but
they're prevented from doing so because
it's behind that paywall like you've
already signed up for four other
streaming services and you don't want to
sign up for a fifth one so it just makes
it really hard to make videos for it
weekly if most people aren't going to be
able to watch because they can't sign up
for the service so what I'm really
curious to see is what CBS will do if
they don't hit the streaming numbers
that they want like if not enough people
sign up will they air some of these
episodes on broadcast as reruns next
year or will they wait and roll out some
free tiers so that you can stream it for
free with more ads so I think from a
business perspective they have to work
some of that out but we'll see like
whatever ends up happening I'll do a
video for it at least by the end of the
season is sort of a wrap up but just for
reference I will be watching every week
and for those of you asking about
the Orville 2 I also watch that every
week too but obviously I haven't been
making videos for it but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Brett
Simpson you win a CBS all access pass
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details what will happen is is
there'll be some new Rick and Morty next
there'll be some new DC TV they just
confirmed that Legion of super-heroes
are coming to the DC TV show so there's
a bunch of comic book stuff coming up
there'll be new Game of Thrones while
you wait for everything you can click
here for my Discovery episode 1 video
and you can click here for brand new
Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight